the area here in southeastern Ohio is
what you will call like Appalachia
[Music]
you're not familiar with the appellation
of region we could pretty much sum it up
by saying
poor uneducated
yeah you can turn down factories they're
tearing down houses people are legit
struggling
[Music]
and socially speaking when you're not
helping society move forward your your
found any turn to see it crumble in
front of you
my name is Billy white I'm a tattoo
artist in Zanesville Ohio
it's simple I tell people all the time
that like I really feel like my
community is 30 years behind - do you
want me to I don't even know if I know
what that is personally Jessica earlier
I think she called it I think it was a
Facebook message it's been overwhelming
I guess uh it's it's been eye-opening to
to find out you know that a lot of this
stuff does exist and that it is you know
I've even tattooed some of these guys
and didn't know they had this kind of
stuff on them and then boom here we are
and were covering it up as long as I can
remember we're living in the most toxic
time I've ever lived
[Applause]
society's belief systems are seeing you
changing or reverting back into the time
that I've thought
[Music]
[Applause]
so I'm seeing this and I'm thinking to
myself like my god this person died
people are
kill for the right
I
turning stand back
as I often do what can I do
we're drawing to cover it you know
making the design a little bit busy so
he can hide the image in it all right
have a seat up here take your shoes off
if you want whatever is most comfortable
for you but up here for me dude how long
ago did you have this done
um it's probably been about five years
was it done at a shop yeah but not by
somebody that was licensed shoot tattoos
right so I came in to get a swastika
tattoo covered up on my foot
[Music]
I was I in a bad relationship and the
guy was a white supremist so he inspired
it and I got drunk enough on Wild Turkey
that I decided to do it
he was abusive it was a definitely a
mental thing as well so I just took us I
took on his beliefs you know and I mean
I really did feel that way at some point
in time but I mean I don't know
[Music]
in home daycare and my kids that I watch
are biracial so it's embarrassing yeah
come on back man because of the my
social media outreach you know a lot of
people want once I say share its it
spreads like wildfire I have you come
around here for me on this side of the
table
we'll get the stencil on you my man and
we'll go from there
and it happens you see in both both
sides you see people that are super
stoked for the person and that are
really happy that the person is moving
on and then you have the people that are
like well what they have done it if it
wasn't for free kind of thing
I don't care that it's for free or I
don't care why they got it
I just feel like I have to do something
[Music]
right now live in thorn Ville Ohio
originally from North Ohio spent 15
years down in Malta Ohio I was born and
raised here in circle villa hi
[Music]
my dad was alcoholic mom was an
alcoholic growing up that's all mom and
dad did it was drank
[Music]
that was very racist
rest of my family my uncles and stuff
was very racist and negative toward
everybody and then when I was 16 years
old dad when everybody has committed
suicide
their point on my life I actually hated
everything I didn't care who it was
white black eye
I'm ended up going down a path that most
people never go down
[Music]
and it really took a big change to pull
me out
[Music]
spoon oh man let me see your back I
wanna get a trace you know it real quick
see what we're working with you know
still this day I'll sit back and
thinking what the hell was I thinking
I was like that all the way up until I
was about 27 years old a couple years
later me and ex-wife was talking about
adopt and end up adopting little boy out
of Florida because that's my son I don't
want my son to know that his dad
participated in that my son now is 12
years old and one of greatest kids you
ever meet I mean loving boy loves made
deaf love him death life of hate it's
just not what you want don't want live
life
[Music]
baby you'll set new brand some clouds
over top of that works for me I'll do
her
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
people get like that because they don't
understand or want to understand where
they're afraid to try to understand I
think I found myself now and I'm happy
with who I am and the way my life and
the path and my life is taken all right
man I'm gonna start mixing up some
colors I need to mix up right quick like
how I know tattoos are so powerful cuz I
mean I'm sitting here and I'm getting
all these tattoos lasered off of my face
you know I'm taking them off my face
because I don't like the way it makes
people perceive me it's not because they
don't mean anything to me
they actually mean more to me yeah they
mean a lot to me cuz I got them all for
like my parents when they passed away
and I'm on the cusp of my mom's birthday
makes me all motional and [ __ ] so uh I
lost my parents 49 hours apart seven
years ago in April
[Applause]
you know they're right here but that
doesn't mean it can't make them proud I
want to make them proud I want to make
my kids proud
so when I'm gone they're not like here
my dad was just a guy you just did that
you know maybe he did something
[Music]
a couple on that for you John yeah
appreciate it
take a look what you think man
definitely gives a new start to things
man I really does I'm gonna keep doing
these things I'm gonna keep covering up
this stuff forever as far as I'm
concerned
glad I feel for you definitely makes me
feel better and it's definitely better
dangling oh [ __ ]
now you'll definitely feel it - really
changed my life dude good man so I think
that's what we plan on doing already
thank you so much man you're awesome
welcome I really appreciate that
I'm just gonna keep trying to you know
day by day make the world's maybe a
little bit better a place if it's
possible
[Music]